في الوقت الذي تزيد فيه معايير التطور في
مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي يبدو ان حقوق
الانسان احد اهم الامور التي قد يلحقها
ضرر كبير من هذا الذكاء وذلك بحسب ما تحذر
منه الامم المتحده المفوضيه الساميه لحقوق
الانسان في المؤسسه الدوليه الشهيره ترى
انه من الضروري وضع محاذير فعاله لاجل
ضمان كرامه الانسان وحقوقه التي اعتبرتها
في خطر كبير وحظت عشرات الدول بينها
الولايات المتحده والصين هذا الاسبوع على
وضع تنظيمات لتطوير ذكاء الاصطناعي
واستخدامه في المجال العسكري وحذره من
عواقب غير مرغوب فيها واعرب النص الذي
وقعته اكثر من 60 دوله عن مخاوف متعلقه
بمساله انخراط البشري اضافه الى انعدام
الوضوح على الصعيد المسؤوليه والعواقب غير
المقصوده المحتمله